actor todd lawson la tourette status as
a war veteran and amputee has helped him
carve out a decent career in hollywood
it's a somewhat unconventional angle but
it worked for la tourette who has scored
small parts in big films like the George
Clooney war comedy the men who stare at
goats as well as roles in series like
Netflix's modern Western crime drama
Longmire and most recently a lot to read
appeared in the critically acclaimed
better call Saul fans of the Breaking
Bad spinoff series will recognize lot to
read from the season 4 episode quite a
ride which aired on AMC on September 3rd
la tourette scored the gig due in part
to his missing appendage which he
previously claimed was the unfortunate
outcome of an injury he sustained while
serving overseas however it turns out
that was a total lie speaking with
Albuquerque NBC affiliate KOB for
LaTourette revealed that he isn't really
a war veteran and that he didn't lose
his hand and part of his arm during
active duty in reality he cut off and
cauterized his own hand and that lied
about his identity as a military vet in
the hopes of landing roles in film and
on television la tourette sli's helped
him achieve his goal
but the guilt is fibbing left him with
far outweighs the benefits he's reaped
la tourette explained that the incident
took place in 2001 when he wasn't taking
medications meant to help him manage his
bipolar disorder he told the station I
severed my own hand with the state of my
mind was a psychotic he added that
Hollywood believed his story and nobody
questioned how he became an amputee and
he was seen as a unique casting
opportunity his missing limb and how his
character lost it was even a plot point
in this episode of the CW's supernatural
drama the messengers how exactly did you
lose it
I was riding shotgun in a Humvee in
Kandahar the attention and praise may
have felt good in the moment but it
didn't last forever and left LaTourette
feeling guilty LaTourette who was
reportedly back on his bipolar disorder
medication as of the making of this
video
noted that he is fully aware of the
consequences and fallout that will
result from his confession but felt it
was crucial to come clean about see
myself from the Mexico film industry and
gladly so just to say what I've said
he was also candid in stating that he
doesn't expect anyone to forgive him for
his wrongdoings but he remains hopeful
that him opening up about his struggles
with mental illness and the extreme sis
bipolar disorder drove him to will
motivate others to seek help if they
need it the power is in your hands to
take that medication in the morning or
at night so that this this course of my
life doesn't need to necessarily be
yours if you or someone that you know is
struggling with mental illness call the
Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services Administration's national
helpline at 1 800 662 help visit the
National Institute of Mental Health
online at the address on your screen or
call the National Suicide Prevention
lifeline at one eight hundred two seven
three eight two five five
[Music]